with wind gusts reaching 60 miles per
hour and snow sprinkling Across The
Valleys Tuesday's extreme weather really
made an impact at grounded Plains caused
some power outages and as Ryan Matthey
found blue trash cans away causing
damage
well Valentine's Day is extreme weather
through both lovers and trash cans off
their feet one man here in West
Summerlin saying the winds blew a trash
can from up here
oh
down here into his new car a lot of
other trash cans come racing down this
hill at me I actually had to jump out of
the way a grouping of receptacles blown
outside Wayne Sullivan's front door
Tuesday waking up Wednesday to find
another one making impact with his new
2023 Toyota Tacoma didn't look very bad
at first there's maybe a dent right here
but when you really look at it it pushed
this whole piece in about two inches
there's a big gap right here now how
much it'll cost to fix it I have no idea
but I'm pretty sure it's going to be
more than my deductible
impact stretching Valley Wide raging
winds in Boulder City to snow flurries
from the Northwest to the strip across
Clark County winds inflicting power
outages for over 14
000 customers at its worst it is prime
conditions we have some great snow right
now Brian Snow landing on Mount
Charleston says Leone with Southern
Nevada Conservancy later this year when
the snow melts it's great it replenishes
the Springs but with an upcoming holiday
weekend a potential increase in visitors
heading up the mountain draws
overcrowding concerns when we say get
there by 8 AM or 9 A.M we're not joking
the we get 10 000 cars a day as long as
people are staying out of the back
country it's a relatively safe place to
go as long as people are being safe and
bringing the right equipment for their
snow play that's what you're supposed to
do with your trash can it's not their
fault to win and and the hill brought it
now if you're heading up to the mountain
this President's Day weekend they add to
stay in public spaces such as the ski
resort where Avalanche mitigation is in
place they do not recommend anyone
traveling outside these areas due to
Avalanche concerns